[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing dumbledore
lily potter and the night that voldemort
entered the home
of the potters more specifically i'm
going to be discussing
lily potter's loving sacrifice and how
on earth
dumbledore knew that the sacrifice had
occurred he wasn't there
in fact no one was there so how did he
know about lilly's sacrifice to save
harry
how did he know how harry had survived
how did he know that harry would be
protected for years and years
after the fact in this video i'm going
to be answering all of those things
after the potters had been killed there
was little trace of the events that had
transpired
there was a severely damaged home the
corpses of lillian james
and baby harry who had just obtained his
lifelong and iconic scar
it was obvious that something happened
but what
in fact there was so little evidence in
the home that it would be hard to figure
out
that voldemort was even defeated let
alone figuring out that lily had saved
harry
through a loving sacrifice
simultaneously ending voldemort
nevertheless dumbledore seemed to know
everything
the following passage from the order of
the phoenix suggests that dumbledore
knew
exactly what happened that night but i
too where voldemort was weak and so i
made my decision
you would be protected by an ancient
magic of which he knows
which he despises and which he has
always therefore
underestimated to his cost i am speaking
of course
of the fact that your mother died to
save you
she gave you a lingering protection he
never
expected a protection that flows in your
veins to this day
i put my trust therefore in your
mother's blood
i delivered you to her sister her only
remaining relative
she may have taken you grudgingly
furiously unwillingly
bitterly yet she still took you and in
doing so
she sealed the charm i placed upon you
your mother's sacrifice
made the bond of blood the strongest
shield i could give you however
not only did dumbledore know that lily
was responsible for saving harry
and ending voldemort he knew the ins and
outs of it
he knew the exact type of magic that she
had used
a powerful love-based magic dumbledore
also found all this out fairly quickly
as by the time harry was delivered to
the dursleys he seemed to know
both harry's protection and the dark
lord's defeat
he even seemed confident enough to leave
harry with the dursleys
his entire protection based off of
dumbledore's supposed
understanding so how did dumbledore know
all of this if you had asked me this
question before the existence of
fantastic beasts
then i would have had a different answer
for you but with the advent of the new
films fortunately we should be able to
surmise a likely answer
it isn't confirmed but in my opinion
it's a pretty good one
my initial feeling before the better
explanation coming in a minute
was that dumbledore and snape simply
assumed what had happened
based off of snape's interactions with
the dark lord dumbledore knew of snape's
request to voldemort that he spare lily
which means that if they were under the
impression that voldemort would keep his
word
and lily died anyway it's an easy
inference to make that she refused to
step aside
sacrificing herself dumbledore is also a
wise old powerful wizard
familiar with all kinds of powerful
magic so it's not unreasonable to expect
that he would have a good understanding
of the power of a loving sacrifice
assuming he understood this kind of
magic it would have seemingly also
clarified voldemort's death
okay so that was my first assumption my
second assumption was that dumbledore
simply showed up at the house
and used some kind of powerful magic to
relay the events of the evening
interestingly enough this is pretty
close to the real answer
in the fantastic beasts films which were
released years
after the last of the harry potter books
we are introduced to a new spell
apparate vestigium in the crimes of
grindelwald newt's commander
in search of tina cast the previously
unknown spell
from what we can tell the spell seems to
reveal and expose
traces of recent magic by use of some
kind of gold powder
the known effects of this spell in
conjunction with dumbledore's
own words that magic always leaves a
trace
very distinctive traces makes
dumbledore's use of this spell in the
potter residence
highly likely using apparate vestigium
del model would have been able to
successfully expose every detail of the
evening
he would have first been able to see
voldemort offering to spare lily
followed by lily rejecting his proposal
from there he would have witnessed
voldemort's killing curse famously
backfiring
sparing harry's life and ending
voldemort's to conclude
i am nearly entirely confident that this
is the spell the dumbledore used
particularly as lily's loving sacrifice
on harry is such an important driver of
this series
not only that but harry's guaranteed
protection from voldemort
is an integral part of dumbledore's plan
what do you guys think
did dumbledore use apparate vestigium
let me know in the comment section
below until next time remember
there is no good and evil there is only
power and those too weak
to seek it
you